the pm on his morning run but there's no
escape in the crisis engulfing his
number 10.
today on a hospital visit in milton
keynes praying perhaps for respite can
you guarantee that no more embarrassing
allegations will come out before that
report is published what i can guarantee
is that this government is focused
100 percent on dealing with the big
problems
his problems rather than the
one countries stories emerging about
what happened in the lockdown of 2020
on june the 19th the prime minister's
birthday on a visit to a school that
morning but later that day it emerged in
this very room the prime minister's wife
and up to 30 others surprised him to
celebrate with a birthday cake and
singing at a time when indoor social
gatherings were banned i do think that
in this saga there have been some quite
serious allegations made those have been
investigated i don't think that these
latest allegations that have been made
fit into that category i think they've
gone slightly over the top
but tonight senior members of the party
questioning the pm's ability to carry
this beth this breaks my heart this is
damaging for
my party this is damaging
for my country do you think he should
resign
um
i genuinely hope beth that the prime
minister takes a long hard look at the
current situation and makes a judgment
by himself i think you're saying he
should fall on his sword i think i'm
saying that i hope that he can live by
what i know he has which is a love for
this country and decide whether he
continues to be the right person to lead
it
and that question becomes more pressing
by the hour as the johnson
administration plunges further into
crisis every day brings more
trouble new party revelations accusation
of racial discrimination bullying even
blackmail
mps are in open civil war and boris
johnson and his government are becoming
a public spectacle
one senior tory tells me tonight that
the majority of mps still want him to
get a grip but the longer this chaos
continues the harder that becomes
the opposition say don't wait for sue
grey to report go now we've got a prime
minister and a government to spend their
whole time mopping up sleaze and deceit
meanwhile millions of people are
struggling to pay their bills and we
can't afford to go on with this chaotic
rudderless government the prime minister
is a national distraction
he's got to go and not the only one
westminster's snp leader has spent weeks
calling for a resignation tonight no
different i'm pretend saying it was a
brief gathering he had a cake he stayed
for 10 minutes then he went on with
his work what's your
view about this
he simply doesn't get it
how ordinary folk feel
we were all told everyone up and down
the united kingdom that we had to obey
the rules that we had to socially
distance that we couldn't have family
gatherings we couldn't be with loved
ones at a time of need we couldn't
grieve properly
and here is a prime minister
that had a birthday party at number 10.
my message to boris johnson tonight is
go
go now
that question now hinge in on a report
by the senior official sugree
is the report nearly finished
all of us still in the dark about what
that report into number 10 parties might
say but no one in any doubt about what
rests on it beth rigby sky news